all right people of the internet we are
here getting ready to tackle the haunted
hogsmeade shop Quest we're recording
this live doing it live over on Twitch
chat's telling me guys they're telling
me like I really need to prepare so
they're wanting me to go and stock up on
supplies so we're gonna head into our
room of requirement first have a good
supply of wig and weld we're we're at
Max wiggin weld okay so that's good
we're 25 wig and weld already we don't
really have to worry about Brewing any
of those oh I'm excited man
you guys have been hyping this up
been hyping this Quest up for a while
hello Madam Mason I hear you have a
shallow cell Madam Mason
I understand yourself why yes yes I do
are you interested dude they changed her
design
I am indeed yes I am I've always wanted
to own a shop
less
I think you will find my chins why
Jervis but and do please forgive me for
asking don't you think you might be a
Chad Young no don't you see these robes
I'm wearing
my age is irrelevant if I have the money
I have a little bit more of this sort of
thing if I do say so myself
if I can meet your terms I hope that
you'll sell to me well yeah dark Hearts
this is the px5 and that PS5 PlayStation
exclusive for one year that elf could
sell tea to a troll I assume she told
you she comes with the place she did
indeed I like you tell you what I shall
sell you the space for an exceedingly
fair price
I think you might just be sure enough to
make a go if you use AK oh my goodness
exceedingly fair price for a shop and an
elf
what's the catch ha
you are wise to be wary business
dealings no catch really I simply ask
that you allow me to do you the face
back
discounts of course should your efforts
fail the last thing we need here in
hogsmeade is for One Bad Apple to spoil
the barrel if you get my meaning
oh you just wait Cassandra
your faith in me is overwhelming he
sounded like absolutely mistaken if you
think I'm going to fail there's that
confidence again um
I wish you every success do we have a
deal oh she's confident too though she's
come oh maybe I should
what represents failure precisely do you
mean should my efforts fail honestly I
only mean
you're unable to keep the shot going
okay
that's all gotcha gotcha as you've
implied the odds of that happening are
remote they are indeed
all right it does sound intriguing no
you need to consider my finances we
don't need to consider it retro we'll
find you if I'm interested very well but
I won't be able to keep the shop
available for too long all right you
know what I thought about it I'm ready I
want it
about the shop yes I've decided I'd like
to go ahead and purchase the shop I have
to say I'm impressed you are a
remarkably resourceful student I am
indeed and brave you won't be sorry give
me the money and I shall get the
paperwork filed immediately yep yep I'm
not sure about this they give you a
chance to back out wonderful shall I
head directly to the shop please do oh
one more thing since my husband died
I wonder if he's the
they're in a chest at the back of the
shop pet Studio I think's the name get
organized Poltergeist you would be
grateful if you could help an old Widow
and gather his things for me before you
open for business oh sure sure I wish
you the very best of luck we got your
endeavors
hey Penny let's do this together Penny
Wonder well I've done it Penny the shop
is mine oh penny is so pleased and he
was hoping you would be the one don't
worry Penny I won't hold it against you
you're here to help me goodness what a
kind thing to say I feel like you just
won out of this too she can to make this
a success
there is much to do the Last Tenant left
in a bit of a rush so we'll need to
Christy welcome repairs
no time like the present I'm already
exhausted
well then let's get together
with us we should have this place up and
running in no time all right all right
all right hold on before we go in you
guys all right
whatever's in here dude we gotta let
them know
we gotta let them know who they're
dealing with here all right so
as but I mean this is my favorite rope
in the game
but right now
we gotta let them know we we ain't
playing around
we playing around
so we're gonna go with that
and you know what hold on hold on
nah two nah
no we need to let we need to like I
don't know maybe full maybe full dark
arts
maybe like
maybe niffler mask
I don't know I think that one I think
that's the one dude
I think that's the one oh geez let me
what penny come on now
this place is an absolute disarray what
is going on
all right let's go ahead
tidy up a bit here
you guys were making it out like this is
some scary Quest all all we're gonna be
doing is repair
come on now
oh man
yeah retro we're actually just all you
do is it's a cleaning Quest actually
wanted Penny to be sure and give you
this key
it opens a chest in the back room oh
it's too funny oh yes she mentioned it
to me it contained some of her late
husband's belongings Penny wonders if
you should open the chest
penny come on Penny
get back to work now how are you gonna
do how are you gonna set us like set us
up like this penny
revelio
oh see Chad there's one thing we can't
forget we can't forget about the loot
like we gotta
we gotta make sure we're on the lookout
for plenty of loot
oh this is just an unassuming chest here
little eye staring at me okay all right
all right
I can't believe she just totally sets us
up I want to know what the house house
motives are oh but she's probably it's
all set up by the owner
it's all set up by Cassandra
oh yeah just crawl down there retro that
sounds great not don't even check in
with the house self we just going in we
just going right in there all right
I mean I know you got the dark Arch robe
you got the mask we're ready to do this
okay
oh my gosh that look she just shut it on
us too
ladder gone
oh yeah look no fear in that face no no
no no no
like Dobby hitting himself yeah yeah
yeah
mind your business is the side quest
name
all right
I already feel the tension
okay let's see revelio dude you know
it's not a good sign when revelio's not
not showing much of anything repair of
this oh come on
don't want to let me repair that all
right fine
so I guess it's just like a big money
scheme you know that she just she wants
people to just go in then they get so
terrified
that they come back
and they're like oh no you take it there
they are dude there they are
oh my gosh the one right behind me
take that
yeah I don't like the way you're looking
at me
they're you
revelio
okay all right
don't like the way you're just sitting
here yep don't like that don't like you
at all like you're just the most
innocent little pose of all do not like
it
someone stole one hat in here
haha
oh my gosh I'm sorry why would someone
stole one hat in here
[Music]
oh whoops were we not supposed to do
that
oh man that's actually really cool
that's what I did blast them I know dude
like I don't even want you looking at me
don't stare at me
oh man but now it's gone
okay so all right we picked up the Hat
oh dude I'm calling it now that's what
we're gonna give penny at the end of
this gonna give her her Freedom okay
it's not an actual hat it's a quest item
gotcha all right well I don't see
hospitable oh okay I was like I don't
see anywhere else we're supposed to go
bro
for me oh I need I gotta hold on I gotta
turn up the volume
not gonna turn it you guys are like oh
he's actually turning it no I want to
turn it up dude I want to be in this I
want to be in this with you Chad turn up
your volume two
turn up your volume right now we got
this we're in this together
I mean look it's just you know some
mannequins
oh dude now that lumos when the light
goes out man
all right okay
our tried and true has been revelio
that's new
what who's that
that's not really fair
all right fast Studio where you at dude
where you at
I'm gonna try every door
oh that's okay
see you in there
boom I don't want you looking at me
I'm still trying every door dude
revelio we have to keep checking and
make sure we don't miss any loot you
know lumos
lumos
oh dude look at that
all right
the game's just like nah don't even
worry about loot right now
oh interesting okay so the little
creepy Jack in the Box is like
not quite like a port key
revelio
boom
thank you guys for the follows welcome
welcome in welcome in
turn your lights down low
turn the headphones up
revelio
okay wait what the heck it says Stupify
is that say Stupify
no
revelio all right we need to find that
little uh Jack-in-the-Box again
my gosh
jumped at the pot freak literally
nothing else has scared me so far but
that that pot the glass breaking
oh my goodness
okay well I guess we go back here now
okay no doors anymore
oh we still got our Dash ability too
lovely
that's nice
they didn't take that away from us
[Music]
really it's just happy little paintings
seems as if I should hang something
there
ah where at we already have stuff on
both sides
okay we got a light on this side no
light on this side
light over here
these lanterns must belong somewhere
lanterns must belong somewhere
it wasn't what I was going for but okay
oh what did he just say he just said
something about perhaps the lantern
something
all right here we go okay nice
but I don't know where maybe you're
supposed to hang right here with the
hand
nice all right
okay that wasn't there before
oh nice you might survive a bit longer
than the other phone
lumos
all right
nothing here revelio
where's the loot game come on
we're gonna go through this we at least
gotta get some loot oh you've come so
far so quickly well done there he is
just the playmate I've been looking for
I do hope you enjoy my playground I
encourage you to tell everyone about it
if you make it out that is
please try if you get to the end perhaps
we can come to some sort of arrangement
I do want to listen to succeed after all
I don't believe you
are unfortunately for you oh my goodness
gracious
oh we could destroy it guess not
all right so we have two basically two
Quest markers
and I guess we can go either way
you'll need more than you've learned
from books to best interesting
scholarly
all right well it looks like I don't
really have to worry about loot that
much which is I mean that's kind of a
good thing because I don't really have
to worry about missing missing things
oh it's the lantern again okay
don't mind me poltergeist just looking
for a little Lantern
any lanterns in here
lanterns lanterns
no lanterns
do you have a lantern dude
Lantern all right no Lantern
lumos
this is crazy dude
I hate how your wand goes out like when
you cast oh wait we've
I was gonna say this is a setup
definitely don't want us aren't gonna
let us leave that easily all right so we
went through the right door last time
let's try this one
ow lumos
apparently I needed to dash away
from that
oh come on I was ready for that one too
hmm running no that's so cool dude
face yourself oh that's so cool
all right fine we'll go back
as you should retrace your step
jeez what was that it was a spider
that's what it was
oh my gosh I knew I was I was about to
make the comment chat of when are the
spiders coming
when are the spiders
out of my face dude
you guys are up too close
I don't like
look at me dude hey I'm I'm as scary as
anything down here look at that
oh no lumos not not extending out as far
now
lumos okay so we got the doorway there
I don't think this is gonna yeah it's
just gonna make sure
oh hello
they make you hold it down forever
oh how nice it is
lumos
I love how they're not even hurting me
and I'm just still like okay I'm gonna
all right well the the quest marker is
pointing this way
but
I'll do there everywhere now they're
just everywhere
lumos
all right nice to know our ancient magic
is still
pretty freaking powerful
all right dude I might need to switch up
my spells actually
because I feel like we need lumos on at
all times
no not repero not reperto
you miss
Ed
see
come on
you want to go
let's go
let's go buddy how about you too nah
okay
all right so the mini map is definitely
a nice Advantage here
because you can see them you can see how
many there are
at least right now
see I almost think it'd be cool if they
took that away
oh that's cool
lumos yeah I'm really
I'm really not looking for uh for tips
or anything so appreciate you guys
chatting and throwing out the tips but
I'm just kind of being I'm just kind of
being all in this right now so hopefully
you guys are
hope you're enjoying the commentary here
all right there's our Lantern which is
really how this all
all dude you think that's him you think
that's fastidio
who's
with wrong button yeah and guardian
Leviosa
oh yeah now we're back to the wizard
statue
and there we go
oh no do we need two of them
Maybe
oh yeah I see it I wonder if I need to
place lanterns to open these doors okay
so now we need an additional Lantern
revelio
where can I move that one
yeah we needed we need an additional one
I think but it keeps pointing me in that
direction
okay that was unexpected
good to have a different perspective
am I supposed to jump down
no but I bet we can do new stuff now
this way lumos
I bet we can do different stuff this way
now
revelio
look at all these portraits in here too
okay we're looking for another Lantern
lumos
oh yeah here we go so this is we were
just we were right there
and I think that's the lantern we're
looking for wait can I Accu it from here
oh my gosh let's go
wait I guess I have to put it here
probably
my head is
I kind of wanted to just try to go back
to that other room honestly and put it
there because I think that's what I need
to actually progress but
clearly I think the game it it was
wanted me to put it right there so
although this this whole level is all
about faking you out and stuff so
maybe I should have went with my first
instinct tried to take it back to the
original room
okay wait isn't it isn't that
dude revelio is just like lumos no use
here
okay we need another Lantern
okay wait this is where we just
were
right
oh there's one
Guardian Leviosa
oh no there's one right there I'm gonna
take it to the other one
I'm gonna not do
oh oh it blocks me off
okay well maybe that means
now I don't have to be uncertain about
if I'm taking it to the right one or not
foreign
so we're upside down here
well oops I should pull the lantern into
this room to cause the room to rotate
again pull the lantern
where is it
oh wait I can
oh okay I see I see I see hold on put it
back
gotta use the window
that's weird that it wouldn't let me
move the lantern earlier though
in that other spot
oh no
uh Lantern
oh thank goodness
I thought we just lost it right there
look at a little hand look at the hand
reaching out
I'm waiting
I'm waiting for the lantern
lumos all right lumos
lumos is your best friend revelio I
don't know why I keep doing revelio guys
it's just habit at this point oh wait a
second though wait a second
okay so it does at least show you the
lanterns and it does show you like the
big Blues
Leviosa
all right back to the door
there we go
open
what do you got for me now fastidio
oh look it's like here have a few wig
and welds look at that we already maxed
out dude
we already maxed out on the Wigan welds
boss fight boss fight
oh wait it actually may be
what the heck
I can't lock on
okay he can do damage to you though
okay I can lock on to that
[Applause]
I can't lock onto him
self if collect ourselves
look at me dude
does this wizard look like they need to
collect themselves no we ready we ready
fastity oh what you got next dude what
you got next
come on now
don't run like that
we're ready for the final trial
talking like this like it helps me build
myself up guys just just trust me okay
trust me okay well this area doesn't
look too crazy I'm just gonna go where
it's leading us though
got the plants
nice okay there is some loot
oh Wigan weld
we can welds again
I I know about the doors dude I'm just
exploring hold on hold on
it's lanterns
okay no Lantern there
and then let's see if we can destroy
this
yep
thank you guys for all the new follows
by the way welcome in welcome in
[Music]
all right more spider webs okay so we
had I'm trying to we've got two here
I'm pretty sure that's how you progress
to the next major area
and then we have one in here that looks
like another one that's gonna flip the
room or something oh
I mean can I just
Wingardium Leviosa
oh darn it
did the thing again
it did the thing
all right well what did that one do
foreign
looks like nothing
hey all good ninja all good
thank you for stopping by and thank you
for following Insidious saw you on
YouTube thought you should drop a follow
hey well thank you for your support on
both platforms really appreciate it
okay hold on so this whole area right
here it just opened this up so yeah I
think we have to go in here
no way
oh my goodness that is so awesome lumos
oh
wait a second
okay I better listen right here nighty
nights the game within a game
all right so I think we're probably not
supposed to walk on the red
that's my guess
all right so let's kind of chart out a
path here
okay yeah I don't like that way that
you'd have to yeah make some interesting
Maneuvers there
all right so let's go here
oh no
oh no wait let's go here
revelio
see I don't know if I can go diagonally
I'm not even gonna risk it
I really
slow
oh you know we gotta go for the chest
okay I think I see how to get it though
we need to just get to the end all right
I'm just going to test this out if I
step on here with you do you get mad oh
you can't
okay you actually can't so I think I was
doing it right I think you have to just
completely Rebellion
no hold on though
can I move you with a spell
nope we could try it's a good try
revelio
yeah we can't go any of those directions
I don't see any way to move you
I don't feel like you can step
diagonally
you can okay good good
all right checking for any more
that wasn't too difficult
don't say that dude they're gonna change
something up on us
all right here we go there we go
chess pieces can move diagonally good
point good point oh goodness I do hope
you're having as much fun as me
I think I'll keep you around a bit
longer
lumos
all right so we got another
Lantern
or we need another Lantern rather
foreign
gotcha
ravelio
another Lantern okay
all right I think we're at the main door
though I think
thank you guys for the follows welcome
in
appreciate you stopping by
all right so let's do this one
[Music]
all right that side's good
okay now the question becomes did
something change over here
yes it did
revelio
[Music]
man I really like I hate that this Quest
is exclusive because it's really fun
at least it's only time though at least
it is timed so everybody will get it
eventually
wait
okay well
Maybe not maybe I'm not supposed to go
this way
maybe we're supposed to
go the other side
okay yeah here we go
we take no chances here guys
oh look at you trying to just hide right
behind me nah
okay that's gonna fly try to hit me
isn't it
not anymore it's not
not anymore
that ain't right dude that ain't right
incendio
oh just get them all out of my face
right away all right well
let's do this again chat let's do this
again see what's okay
okay all right
oh dude look at this
oh I'm afraid of the dark
doesn't worry you that I can see you but
you can't see me
it should
oh
lumos
all right so we do not have a lantern is
there any we can accio yeah right there
all right it's opening that up but now I
kind of want to see
revelio
I just want to see what
is this oh let's go
okay
all right so now we just have to go back
foreign
[Music]
okay there's another Lantern over there
all right can we accio probably can't
accio that one but I bet we can this one
right here
nothing happened
okay why didn't anything happen
this Quest freaked me out bronny be back
after this Quest
Hogwarts 20 love this game getting it on
switch nice nice
okay what did I did I do something wrong
or
oh wait I think I see I think I see the
path
lumos yeah I'm pretty sure
ouch okay so I need to keep shooting
those pretty sure we have to go over
here and now we're gonna
yeah bring it on this side
put you here
what
has the door not open though
clearly we need to get there or we need
to get this door to open
all right that's so weird
I know I can make that jump
okay wait so can I
all right we can take that one
oh no hold on I'm not sure if we should
do that though
okay so that one is so we could take
that one if we needed it
when I jumped I think it threw me off
or when I when I jumped and fell earlier
I think it threw off my positioning of
where we were at and everything
okay yeah that's where we got that
all right I'm getting turned around that
it's like that's the direction we need
to go
all right let's try this let's go to
this second one
and let's bring over
this Lantern
so we either have to light all three at
once
yeah that one's not doing anything
okay so now we don't have a path there
we don't have a path there
revelio
all right well okay we can get in here
oh
what the heck
oh I see red
well done
[Music]
the combat is so fun in this game
ancient magic
I don't know what that green was about
right there lumos
this just this feels fake dude this
feels fake right here
oh it's actually not okay okay
I thought it was like a fake out chest
it was going to turn into an enemy or
something
all right I think we're good here
[Music]
oh that ain't right dude that ain't
right
oh this is the fake one right here right
here
well I'm shocked right now you guys
if they don't use that as a mechanic at
some point it's a missed opportunity in
here
oh man that would have been so good like
the mimic chest
a little box of uh
I thought it was chocolates no probably
not chocolate
all right so there's the lantern right
there
oh yeah and we're here
Leviosa
nope oh come on get around the corner
there we go
all right fast Studio we're ready
open up
sure nothing
here oh this is like kind of the area
where he attacks you
destroy all of his furniture
don't give him any furniture to use to
throw at me
oh no he's sending out these guys now
can't lock onto him yet
[Music]
lightning bolts just do another one
well this has been fun much to do much
to do see you in a bit come on let me
actually fight you
let me fight you fastidio
okay
revelia
what in the world okay more lanterns
right there at the door oh no wait this
is where we came in
okay that's where we came in right there
okay so we unlocked the other big
latch there so we're able to go all the
way in
a wizard oh my gosh Hagrid
V Nico with the Prime thank you so much
dude
enjoy your ad free viewing on the
channel and the Emoji as well
appreciate you stopping by
e
you my inordinately clever friend all
right let's do it
seemingly never-ending dungeon
relatively unscathed
I don't even think we used a wigging
world oh I suppose you want to go
everyone leaves me usually in a straight
jacket never return I'm starting to take
it personally I'm tired of having no one
to play with
tell you what what's the deal I'll make
you a deal if you can match wits with me
now and do you agree to give me
unfettered access to the shop for say
one day a month to have a little fun
I'll sign the contract
pursuant to which um uh let me see I
will blah blah blah blah blah blah oh
yes he already has it all written up all
other times etc etc you get to shop I
get my chaos and sound acceptable one
day a month
he didn't even give me a chance to agree
or disagree
yeah I've not been able to lock onto him
yet so
I don't think we're supposed to be able
to attack him
oh my gosh look at this
fastidious monster
it's funny almost
okay he's kind of got similar move set
to the troll
oh
man there it is
there you go
finger arrested
whoa
foreign
and now we got the mannequins too
all right so this is probably where the
venomous tentacle a little bit a good
idea let's go ahead and throw on the
honestly I'm gonna do a thunder Brew
and then I'm also gonna do
let's do a Maxima oh see I shouldn't
even worried about the potions
all right
momentum
s
Defender
oh man that extra damage though
try seeing things
that extra damage oh my
what the heck
oh no this I'm just gonna stick to
probably just stick to protegos I'm not
even gonna try to move around oh no now
we have to
dude this is insane
oh my gosh
I am sick right now
[Music]
whoa wrong way
if we got him
but oh my goodness please stop this
before I throw up
someone deserving of the playground eyes
so meticulously crafted such a treat to
have fun again in my little dungeon
I enjoy the challenge I enjoy a good
challenge ah a kindred dare I say spirit
so about the contract that's right I'm
holding you to it dude
uh what are the terms just to be clear
what does this agreement entail
specifically ugh pay attention you
guarantee that I can have my phone I
heard you but each month without fuss I
let you work the rest of the time mostly
in peace
what's in it for you why would you enter
into such an agreement much as I love
banging about the place it's no
comparison to seeing customers faces
when I Bonk them on their heads with the
Frog I know right mostly Stan the value
of an audience until one is without it
hmm
very well I shall agree to your contract
with one small oh it does here at retro
see it in them no more of his
unsatisfying banging about all day in a
pitiful void wait did you say one small
addendum I did
in order that I have a successful shop
with lots of customers would you agree
to causing chaos only after nine o'clock
in the evening hmm seems fair
[Music]
instead of one I would pleasure doing
business with you
oh dear let's go
well done I had a feeling about it
I have to admit Cassandra did a
wonderful job finding the perfect
Playmate are you done festidio
do I just do I leave now
all right goodbye sir
pleasure doing business with you
let's go
is that it is that it is there like
another twist or something do I go back
to her now oh yeah where's that house
self she's gonna be surprised to see me
huh
oh dude oh
and now I can open this
let's go unidentified head item
all right
okay Penny what do you got
I'm back hello penny
are you though penny
are you
oh I'm gonna say of course I'm back are
you worried I might not return Amy was
beginning to think yet another
shopkeeper was going to end up in Saint
Mungus oh my gosh
it's mungo's I think you should explain
penny
Penny please stop waiting your breath
tell me what's going on
how are you forbidden from selling me
because don't I own the shop now
but how can you be forbidden from
telling me what's going on I purchased
this shop
down the shop
right
don't I thank you Penny I think I'm
going to need to talk to the authorities
oh penny is certain that's a brilliant
idea obviously single will know what to
do Penny will wait right here
wait what do I not own the shop all
right Cassandra we're gonna have to have
a talk
I'm keeping the dark arts onto
Cassandra you promised
oh I can't go straight to Cassandra I
have to talk to Ruth
singer
information you might be interested in
ah
you again what can I do for you
Cassandra Mason sold me her shop and
then tried to drive me mad pointed
dungeon I
Sandra
missile you her shop
why are you surprised I am perfectly
capable of owning a shop but I didn't
mean it like that you don't hear the bit
about the dungeon no no I I heard that
bit too and according to the house self
that came with the shop she has done
this sort of thing before repeatedly hmm
I wondered what was going on she seems
to have had a great deal of trouble
keeping a tenant in that shop in any
event these awesome I don't understand
do I not own it
perhaps a little visit with Cassandra is
in order to clear this this I know right
right Jenny just a little bit
just a little bit oh dude officer singer
was running
all right you ready
you ready officer let's go
laughs
she just took off there for a second
[Music]
oh man that was a fun Quest though you
guys are right that was cool
oh it's night all of a sudden
oh hello Ruth I see you've met my new
tenant Cassandra it's my understanding
that you sold your shot and your Elf to
this student now they've been telling me
some very interesting stories about your
business practices perhaps you should
come with me oh
oh
stop
oh my goodness
Cassandra Mason
ladies and gentlemen
what on Earth are they teaching you with
that oh they didn't teach me that
they didn't teach me that one
finger
Oh Cassandra
[Music]
oh my gosh I almost feel bad dude
we're just like
absolutely
going crazy this old lady
come on Cassandra I'm better than to do
business with a wiley story
[Music]
what the heck I thought she was gone
right now
[Music]
come on I want to get an ancient Magic
I want to finish you off with an ancient
magic Cassandra
[Music]
experience oh I've got one I've got one
ready
I don't think it would finish her off
yet though
come on
Maybe
now
take that Cassandra
why is it
I'm disappointed
Sandra dude Ruth come on
everything free roof don't
I always wondered why you couldn't seem
to keep a tenant in that shop of yours I
must admit the notion of a haunted
dungeon across my mind
thanks for this
head back to the shop checking that
house self of yours she's probably
terrified
silencio oh
dang Cassandra Mason and not to worry
Sandra will immediately file the
paperwork needed to Grant you ownership
I know I don't know why the background
switched up like that on her way to
Azkaban thank you officer singer best of
luck to you as the newest shop owner in
hogsmead
all right
fastidio and now it's night whoa fest
video and Cassandra Mason defeated
there she is Penny I have what I hope
will be good news
officer singer confirmed there's
ownership of the shop has now
transferred to me oh well that
that all right penny
now can I give you the little hat time
keeping the truth from you Penny give
her the head to work as hard as she can
for such a kind new owner
yes let's go dude
Penny I found an item of clothes I
called it chat I called it thank you
thank you I told you man as soon as we
picked that up it's my pleasure
you'd serve it
managing the shop for you Penny you're
free you can do anything you've ever
wanted to but all penny has ever wanted
to do oh with a friend and sell to the
villagers in hoxmead if that's what you
want to do Penny then nothing would make
me happier I'm genuinely glad you'll be
staying on Penny is too all that's left
is for you to choose a sign for your new
shop and Penny will take care of the
rest there's a sign
oh stitches and giraffes cladwell and
Brewster vesters and Venom I'm gonna go
cladwell and Brewster I choose cladwell
and Brewster excellent choice have a
look outside thank you I should work on
collecting items for the Shop's
inventory oh and yes I want to see how
this works now nine o'clock every night
all she puts on the little hat yes let's
go